let's just jump in to the first article
we have here from january 4th by a man
named steven marsh
the next u.s civil war is already here
we just refuse to see it
i saw this it's uh it's tagged by the
guardian the far right
and as i was reading it you know there
are some things in it that i was like
okay i don't know if i agree with that i
think you talk about uh voter
suppression and things like that right
that's one of the issues but i was but i
was as i was getting into it and talking
about how we've got these um you know
look a potential political assassination
attempt that that's not uh not
necessarily like a left-right thing with
this black lives matter activist it it
just shows that there's
extremism emerging in this country but
of course you also have serious things
over the past several years like
charlottesville where there's just
clashes in the street yes so let's just
start from the beginning though um you
wrote a book the next civil war
this article is how the next u.s civil
war is already here
i don't write the headlines you didn't
write that yeah so do you think that it
is likely is it is it your opinion or is
it a a journalist's assessment well the
book is really
based on the best available models like
that's what that's that's how i i did it
i tried to keep myself out of it as much
as possible um so you know the leading
experts um that foreign policy did a
survey like their their number was a 67
chance of a civil war um that that also
coincides with polls about average
americans think how likely they think a
civil war is so
you know i feel with this stuff you
don't need to exaggerate it's so scary
anyway that like what i wanted to do in
the book was be as precise as possible
right and use the best available
evidence that i could so
you know yeah there's there's a process
underway in the the united states is a
textbook case of a country ahead of a
civil war on a number of fronts and it's
not one thing it's actually what they
call a complex cascading system so
it's things feeding into each other so
on one hand it's political illegitimacy
on the other hand it's effects of
climate change on the other hand it's
the levels of inequality which which are
at unprecedented levels uh you know
literally levels have that haven't been
seen since 1776
and all of these things contribute to
each other and and factor into each
other and that's why the united states
is kind of in a unique position because
you know all these things are happening
in the rest of the world as well but
it's the way that they feed into each
other that creates such a dangerousness
are there any species are there specific
things that you found factored across
multiple potentials that you just kept
showing up like this is one of these
things that it seems to be in all these
scenarios well the big i mean there are
a few ones that are big like i don't i
don't really separate them out because i
do think they feed into each other but
like the decline of faith of
institutions so the fact that only 20 of
americans believe their electoral system
is fair um you know that's that's right
that's that's a condition that's just
right for civil war um the fact that 33
of americans think that it's okay to use
violence if your side loses and that's
equal democrat republican like it's i
think well they're very similar one's 32
percent one's 36 percent right so that
is a huge factor um so
that's a big one
i'm curious how much of that is honest
and what i mean by that well i you know
i these models are all of different
strengths so like all i can do is tell
you what this is for sure for sure so i
think um you know just leaping off from
there we have the story about uh the
black lives matter activists right uh
accused uh allegedly shooting this um
this this democrat certainly there have
been instances where far right and right
when groups of violence but if you look
at um
institutional support
when it comes to say black lives matter
in 2020 you get kamala harris soliciting
donations to bail out rioters
you have a black lives matter activist
who's arrested for the attempted
assassination of a politician and black
lives matter fronts a hundred thousand
dollars to bail him out you don't you
don't have the same kind of thing on the
right
well um
let me answer that question in two ways
okay so the first thing is that the
process that um civil war experts talk
about and this happens all over the
world happens in chile it happened
in other places at civil war it's called
complementary radicalization so what you
have is
left-wing groups or right-wing groups
taking extremist positions and this
causes people on the other side to get
more radical
so that's that's a that's an area that
transcends
you know uh
partisanship like that's that's now
that's a process that's underway yeah
where
as things get more extreme on the left
they get more extreme on the right that
causes the left to get more extreme that
then causes the right to get more
extreme right and so that's that's a
very toxic uh process that is extremely
hard to escape from now the other thing
i would say is that when i talk to
you know this is just let me just give
you this perspective you can take it or
leave it you know it might be useful to
you it might not be but when i talk to
like members of secret services of other
countries and they're thinking about
what a collapsing america looks like
they're not really afraid of the left
because
the left is inherently self-defeating
uh it is
much less organized than the right like
and it's also
it's much less effective as a as a group
so like when you look at a group like
the oath keepers
they're enormou they they are they have
it together like they they have it they
are to have it together in a way whereas
when you look at left-wing institutions
like the women's march after the trump
inauguration it had you know somewhere
between half a million and a million
people
at its opening rally it explode it
imploded
in internecine politics
almost instantly and like the term woke
institution basically doesn't exist
because they eat themselves right like
so
all i would say is like both both these
processes are underway but i would say
that when when i talked to experts on
civil war from other countries and
people who are worried about the
stability of the united states it was
definitely
far-right extremists that were their
primary words what about the
institutionalization well hold on i
wanted to address this real quick yeah
i don't think you're wrong but uh the
way i say it the way i see it is
the right i would describe as sharp the
left i would describe as blunt black
lives matter was able to raise you know
what tens of millions of dollars
for relatively nebulous causes but that
attracted thousands of people to riot in
the streets over uh 2020. the damage
caused was severe and it did result in a
lot of death but it was very very
widespread so typically what we see a
lot of especially um at the start of you
know donald trump's run for the
presidency i was actually on the ground
at a lot of these these trump rallies
you see uh blunt level terrorism it
never exceeded the the uh it was
political violence
terrorism to me is a technical term that
would not apply to that i mean in terms
in terms of this book like like
terrorism is very specific
like it has very specific
consequences and it's very specific i'm
not to say that we're not dealing with
political violence
violence yeah so political violence to
me is a better term so uh the political
violence you'd see on the left would be
rampant but low scale so there'd be a
lot of evidence of someone getting
punched in the face or someone getting
pushed in the street or people running
around and knocking over garbage cans it
was incessant
it was never rising to the point where
you know uh for a lot of it people were
losing their lives until i think the
riots that but we we've seen right
to me like as an outsider like what
who's right and who's wrong and and the
nature of the violence is less important
to me than the stability of the system
right like as a canadian
up north like wanting america to hold on
so that we can trade with you like what
i'm concerned with is the stability of
the system so you know
like when defund the police happened
right
maybe the worst political idea of
what i mean it's a it's a high bar no
i'm not bored with it but yeah keep it
going we love it for electoral purposes
keep supporting right
but you know also completely non-doable
and
in support yeah well they did in one
place they couldn't get it achieved
anywhere else they got it in minnesota
and then 200 i think 260 departments had
their budgets slashed and then they came
back not all of them i mean but but a
lot of them did come back yeah or chaz
right capitol hill autonomous zone which
is probably the the number one example
of left wing of left-wing
resistance to federal authority i mean
that is a subject in the book but it
it's really very little
it has very little impact when compared
to
the militias
what is the one of lamisha's like so i
can name a ton of things like jazz the
chess chop there was there was that was
in seattle then you also had the
portland attempts you had the occupation
in in minneapolis
well the oath keeper list i mean they
have well obviously january 6th i mean
would be at the top of the list um but
you know as a very highly destabilizing
action but you know like the other thing
about the right is that they're they
understand the importance of
institutions in a way that the left is
not this is you understand i'm i'm not
judging i'm just saying i'm just saying
no i agree like like they like when you
look at the oath keeper list like with
it came out with that 40 000 names like
they'd infiltrated very deeply into
police departments into uh you know
school boards like when i talked to
michael german who's like a who was an
undercover agent for with the fbi and
far-right movements he was like once
they discovered i had no tattoos they
were like you're never going to talk to
anyone rough ever again we're going to
run you on a school board like that's
that's what we're going to do so what
i'm what i mean to say yeah just because
i want to make sure i can let daniel
come in is uh
i think the the one of the reasons
there's a lot of people who who don't
think that the far right elements
uh many people on the right don't think
that there's a big threat from them
because they don't see it a lot right
the way to describe it is it's sharp
versus the left's blunt you know the the
i think you're you're right when you say
that they know the importance of
institutions the right talks about
losing institutional control at the time
what the left doesn't understand uh what
they have is numbers people will go out
in the street and march and smash things
but a day later where are those where
those actions yes and they have no
policy
like they have like they like their
policy ideas are unfeasible well that's
generally true i mean i think i think
like that's true of the left and the
right well what's happening in america
is it's entering a post-policy phase the
government can i mean this is the other
thing we talked about you ask like what
are the major causes like one is this
decline in institutions but it's also
that the united the government is
america's essentially becoming
ungovernable right like like it it know
what like biden has spent 11 months
getting diplomats
in place right it's con the u.s
government is constantly threatening to
renege on its debt i mean that is that's
playing russian roulette with all of
this all of this prosperity the federal
reserve is ungoverned they're they've
never audited it they're there there is
a huge number of ungovernable well you
know to me like as a canadian when you
look at the big build back better bill
or whatever it's called um that's a
budget that's a wednesday in a mature
democracy like you just pass a budget
and that's it in the united states those
are those basic functions of government
are increasingly impossible or extremely
difficult and that leads naturally to a
politics of rage right where it's like
because you can't ever enact policy
whether you're left or right you become
so
everything becomes aesthetic everything
becomes a everything becomes an
aesthetic artistic gesture of your own
anger and your own beliefs in a in a
concept that is that transcends
essentially you know real actions real
government actions and that's that's a
huge to me that's maybe the number one
factor yeah people think they're
supposed to be creating policy they
should be stripping away bad policy
right now so here when i hear american
politicians like think tanks and so on
say like we have to do this with the tax
rate we have to
yeah no no i'm saying no i'm saying pop
your mind
oh sorry sorry sir
um like when i hear them talking about
policy like parental leave or something
it's like you guys can't pass you can
barely pass a budget why are you even
having these conversations about
parental leave or whatever like
you you could you're you're you're in a
system that is increasingly
non-functional and and the thing is like
you know one of the most important
models in the book is that like that is
only going to increase dude i was
watching canadian parliament go nuts and
people were heckling basically i was
like in an american court you would be
thrown out if you heckled well have you
ever seen the british one it's like it's
like it's like a holdover from british
like even the speaker was like you guys
cut it out like they're trying to like
it's 21st century where adults don't
scream over each other they're
definitely not adults they come from
like british parliament where they're
trying to interrupt the guy speaking
they're trying to disrupt them and
british parliament is one of the great
entertainments
of all time what are they called the
questions
well the friday sections it's wonderful
the the question period like the the the
point of a parliamentary system as
opposed to the american system is that
there's a concept of the loyal
opposition so your job is to attack
the government
whether you think they're right or not
and that's just when they're like
and that and that creates that creates
an environment where i d where you know
every leader
has to be humiliated like like every
leader every politician no everyone's
just a servant right and and that's
that's just a completely different
condition in the united states i don't
know if we lost the point you were
trying to make before daniel no i i i
think it's it's it's worth bringing back
not just because it's my point but i
think it touches on what you were saying
of institutions um
so you imagine uh the oath keepers and
you were also talking about black lives
matter in the sense of institutional
uh dysfunction and how i love that you
said the right sees institutions is
inherently necessary
well
or net or valuable um well as
opportunities for advancement of their
own program okay
like that's
both sides now are
destroying the institutions absolutely
but one of the things that i'm curious
about is when you take a group that is i
think incredibly polemic and that does
cause a lot of division which is
something like black lives matter
institutionally
they're they're golden right you have
bank of america who writes them checks
you have the nba you have
major institutions that support what i
think is a purely political entity but
it is held up to this level and i think
that causes a lot of rage because
the oath keepers regardless of what you
think of them would bank of america ever
write them a check they probably
couldn't even get a loan at bank of
america so i think there's institutions
have chosen sides and i think that's
leading to a great greater level of the
of the of the division well the money in
american politics is really confusing
because
like for example like you saw the new
york times article about dark money that
came out like a week ago like i mean
that to me is the most appalling story
in american politics that i know of
where
the money that 2.4 billion dollars that
decided the 2020 election no one knows
where it came from some of it came from
foreign sources for sure but nobody
knows where it came from now 1.5 billion
came went to the democrats and 900 000
went to the republicans
so 900 million sorry 900 million yeah um
did i say billy you said nine hundred
thousand went to the oh right uh my
canadian small-time politics stuff but
uh
that's
and and so you you and then there's the
other fact that like
while republicans are pro-business and
so on like 70 of american gdp comes from
biden voting counties that seems to me
like one of the key facts that's going
to determine the future of this country
in civil war or out of it or at the end
of it and so like i think there's
that i i will acknowledge i i find it
confusing like where where money goes to
where is coming from like where what it
is supporting and what it wants i find
it confusing that certain political
causes are are objectively uh acceptance
they're accepted to receive money or to
be on the board or write a check to and
others are not because those causes are
aligning more and more well the cox
brothers
a knicks game and at the halftime show
have them give a 500 000 check
to this political cause but you will see
it for
something like black lives matter you
will see it for something like planned
parenthood you will see so the the the
philanthropy of politics i think has
become very very divisive because
certain philanthro philanthropic groups
are are tolerable and others and real
quick yeah
it's only one koch brother the other
right sure right but just you know i
thought that was right well they i think
they also stopped giving money to
political causes too like a few years
ago
there's i think they give it to like uh
like reform things they just decided
they're not doing partisan
anymore there are a lot of wealthy
individuals that are willing to fund
either side you know peter thiel well
that's it
is really not who
is giving money to who the point is like
all this money is destroying the system
and making it inherently unstable and
there's also the politicization of
everything which is where you have
homophobic chicken and you have
uh lgbtq positive cookies
like you know like they're where like
literally every aspect of life
is is politicized that also is classic
prelude to civil war thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you